endlich 17 geworden
doch geburtstag ohne gäste
[Musik]
draußen gibt es noch bewegung
drin ist stillstand
erste liebe erste beziehung
[Musik]
doch nur wer wie die stadt
mannschaftssport ohne team ohne
gemeinsame erfolge training allein vor
dem tor 15 monate stand die welt still
auch für teenager ich habe mich selber
besser kennen gelernt ja aber an sich
würde ich ja sagen dass man nicht so
viele chancen dabei waren schon eher
viel gestohlen wurde uns aus der
pubertät einfach und das viele soziale
kontakte auch gestohlen wurden hat
einerseits keine neuen personen kennen
gelernt aber auch mit leuten die man dem
man früher auch vielleicht in der stufe
total eng war ist der kontakt natürlich
ein bisschen abgebrochen in dem alter
geht man auf partys trifft sich mit
vielen freunden probiert verschiedene
dinge ausprobiert seine grenzen aus und
das ist bei uns halt alles irgendwie
weggefallen
man hat vorher gar nicht so richtig
gemerkt was man vermissen könnte oder
was einem sehr viel bedeutet und jetzt
in der cola zeit was man auch verlieren
könnte ich habe oft geweint
[Musik]
die zeit die kann man nicht nachholen
entwicklung und pubertät die kann man
nicht einfach mal auf pausetaste stellen
oder gar auf reset sondern das war jetzt
ein besonderes jahr mit besonderen
bedingungen und hoffentlich kommt jetzt
auch wieder eine andere zeit wo die
jugendlichen auch wieder
erfahrungsmöglichkeiten haben und wo sie
ihren weg suchen und finden können
unterstützung tut gut in schwierigen
zeiten aber auch sonst ist die
beratungsstelle in bielefeld eine
anlaufstelle für eltern kinder und
jugendliche pubertät ist wahnsinn
und diesmal war der wagen hat der
wahnsinn in vier wänden stattgefunden
dass eltern in der pandemie wo familie
aufeinander hockt dass es der stress
gibt und dass die kids als wie vom
anderen stern wahrgenommen werden
deswegen sind sie noch lange nicht
psychisch krank oder psychisch auffällig
sondern das ist der gemeinsame familien
koller der glaube ich im letzten jahr wo
keine familie davon verschont geblieben
ist
daniela reimann kam mit ihrem sohn luca
vor einem jahr zur beratung
luca hatte öfter mist gebaut und
probleme mit seinen gefühlen umzugehen
seine mutter hatte die idee dass er eine
jungengruppe in der beratung besucht
ich habe mir davon versprochen dass er
die möglichkeit erhält mit anderen jungs
in seinem alter sich mal austauschen zu
können weil ja ja so in dem alter
spricht er natürlich nicht mit seiner
mutter über irgendwelche probleme ängste
oder sorgen und ich habe mir gedacht das
tut ihm eigentlich ganz gut dass sie
sich hier vielleicht mal öffnen kann und
sich hier austauschen kann und sich auch
einfach mal so ein bisschen die seele
vom life sprechen kann
ich habe erst mal gesagt auf gar keinen
fall da kriege ich nicht rein habe ich
gesagt ich mache einen tag probe
ich kann mich als festbeißt und danach
nicht jeden tag in gang
luca hat in der gruppe gelernt über
seine gefühle zu sprechen und mit krisen
umzugehen etwas was ihm auch während der
korona zeit geholfen hat wo vieles
fehlte was sonst ein ventil für ihn war
jedoch lebens weil das sportgeschehen
also sport hat mich auch so zu allen
festgehalten und dann wegen kommune
alles weg so drei sportarten die man
gemacht hat wann weg ich hatte dann halt
eher so ein komisches gefühl in mir weil
ich meine wut oder so nicht rauslassen
kommt wenn es mir schlecht ging also
habe ich immer muss man boxt maske
machen also ich habe gelernt emotionen
umzugehen
für viele teenager war die korona zeit
eine herausforderung doch für
therapeuten baumberg die pandemie auch
chancen für jugendliche
diese erfahrung wie man aus krisen
wieder herauskommt halte ich ein gewinn
wenn wir den blickwinkel ändern würden
dann hätten die kinder was gewonnen aber
es wird mehr darauf geschaut dass
bestimmte äußerlichkeiten nicht so
serviert werden konnten
anstatt darauf zu gucken dass die kinder
jetzt in dieser zeit
krisenbewältigung strategien entwickeln
können und sie darin unterstützt werden
würden von daher würde ich nicht sagen
dass die kinder was verloren haben mit
veränderten situationen umgehen dinge
neu denken milder liebt ihren inline
hockey verein doch mannschaftstraining
war viele monate nicht möglich die zeit
ohne gemeinsames training war schwer zu
ertragen
trotzdem hat sie durch die pandemie auch
etwas gefunden so in der schule unseren
sehr schüchterner mensch eigentlich
durch corona irgendwie habe ich gelernt
nicht mehr so viel auf die meinungen
anderer menschen zu hören ich weiß ja
auch gar nicht genau woher das jetzt kam
aber irgendwie bin ich selbstbewusst
einfach geworden indem ich einfach
alleine mehr gemacht habe und dann
gelernt habe ich bin die person ich
werde mit mir mein ganzes leben
verbringen und andere menschen gehen und
kommen und genau dass ich halt einfach
nicht mehr so viel auf andere meinungen
gebe und auf mich selbst höre
scharfes mädchen starker sport und doch
hat die an dem die auf beiden spuren
hinterlassen
ich habe schon so das gefühl dass ich
teilweise auch fast schon depressionen
dadurch bekommen habe auch wenn man also
ich habe er so freundeskreise wo man
sich mit mehreren leuten trifft und
nicht so viele einzelne gute freunde
und dann hat man sich schon öfter mal
einsam und alleine irgendwie gefühl da
hatte ich auch nicht mein sport
irgendwohin irgendwie zu flüchten und
das waren schon so momente die ich dann
mich schon geprägt haben vor einem jahr
verändert sich auch sophie als lieben
nicht nur durch corona sie ist das erste
mal verliebt hat ihre erste beziehung
kontakt beschränkungen sind nicht gerade
hilfreich
also in der zeit hat mir vor allem mein
freund halt gegeben
den habe ich zu anfang der pandemie
kennengelernt und es war oft schwierig
sich so treffen zu können wegen der
verschiedenen logdaten
[Musik]
ja ich denke es ist schon eine belastung
für das erste verliebtsein vielleicht
für die beziehung von mir in meinem
freund aber ich weiß nicht ich kenne es
nicht anders
vieles ist jetzt aber anders auch angst
gehört plötzlich zu sofias leben angst
sich zu infizieren und angst vor schuld
ich hatte sehr viel angst weil zum
beispiel meine mama auch risikopatientin
und da hat man natürlich immer im
hinterkopf zum einen die beschränkung
dass man nicht darf dass man sich nicht
treffen darf mit anderen aber zum
anderen auch dass man es gar nicht will
weil man möchte nicht diesen virus
bekommen was man das kbw aber man möchte
ihn nicht weitergeben an jemanden den es
vielleicht schlimmer treffen könnte als
ein selbst sowie meine mama in dem fall
ich meine das klebt ein ich hoffe
natürlich dass ich es auch irgendwo ein
bisschen loswerde dass ich dann als
erinnerung auf diese angst zurück schaue
und sie nicht noch in meinem kopf
präsent ist und ich trotzdem immer noch
angst habe obwohl die pandemie vorbei
ist jugendliche leichtigkeit ist
plötzlich etwas besonderes und eine
geburtstagsfeier von vielen faktoren
abhängig
johanna hat glück die inzidenz sind
niedrig sie darf ihren 17 geburtstag
feiern
zusammen mit freundin helene bereitet
sie alles vor
endlich können sie mal wieder party
machen in so jungem alter möchte man ja
nicht unbedingt immer nur seinen
geburtstag mit der familie feiern aber
andererseits eine große party zu
veranstalten mit dem vielen leuten dann
halt immer wieder richtig zu feiern das
fehlt einem dann natürlich auch das ist
natürlich dann eine seite etwas traurig
aber auf der anderen seite ist man halt
sehr glücklich dass winkens etwas
stattfinden kann so selbstverständlich
wie das händewaschen gehört mittlerweile
ein corona tester zu dann dürfen die
besten freundin sogar umarmen und sind
keine große party aber johanna feiert
und das zählt auch johannas mutter ist
erleichtert dass dieses jahr der
geburtstag stattfinden kann
viele andere partys wurden bislang
kurzfristig wieder abgesagt ich bin mal
gespannt wie die kinder das leben also
auch wie johanna das ausleben wird die
freut sich natürlich ungemein so in
gesellschaft wieder zu sein und ja im
rahmen wieder zu feiern und alt war so
das leben zu genießen hat aber auch ein
bisschen respekt davor dass dass es doch
noch eine mögliche ansteckungsgefahr
gibt und ich bin einmal ganz gespannt
ich glaube aber dass sie das sehr gut im
griff hat wie sie das ganze aus ballons
und wird
für jeden der in der geburtstagsrunde
bedeutet corona etwas anderes
[Musik]
für mich war keine zeit zum nachdenken
und mich mit meiner zukunft corona uns
ein jahr unsere jugend geraubt für mich
ist corinna eine zeit die mich und meine
familie näher zusammengebracht hat
während ich meine freundin vermisst aber
ich bin froh dass wir das nachholen
können für mich war grüner in der zeit
in der ich gelernt habe die kleinen
dinge im leben zu schätzen durchgerungen
habe ich gelernt über mich hinaus zu
wachsen neue freiheiten erinnern an
normalität und fühlt sich gut an
15 monate war alles anders zeit kann man
nicht nachholen aber man darf sich
freuen auf alles was kommt
klar ist immer noch da aber jetzt wo man
ein bisschen freiheiten hat und wo man
wieder wegfahren kann und wo man sich
mit freunden treffen kann
das fühlt sich einfach wieder normal an
und ich will wieder zurück zur
normalität also ich würde mir vielleicht
wünschen dass momentan wir uns noch ein
bisschen gedulden können so dass wenn
wieder alles normal ist wenn mal wieder
ein bisschen lärm in kona besiegt ist
sage ich mal dass wir dann wieder normal
leben können und das ja wir unsere
erfahrung machen kann als jugendliche
ich denke meine generation wäre das auf
jeden fall alles nachholen und ich denke
auch dass wir solche leute sein werden
die möglich doch wohl fühlt sich dann
vom klub stehen und dann kommen die
alten knacker die dann noch mal in die
jugendlichen zeigen wie es jetzt
wirklich gehst weil wir schon viel
verpasst haben und dafür leben wir dann
umso länger dass jugendliche leben
[Musik]